hi everyone I'm Millie Bobby Brown and
I'm going to be playing with puppies
while answering fan questions bring them
in me I can't focus this is either
licking my neck the CGI is the raw the
sounds the I can't focus the characters
I mean when you take away the monsters
it's this it's still a great movie and
when you add them in it's still a good
movie so I like I like the human aspect
of the movie well it's like xi has a lot
of power but maybe not that much that's
so heavy to think about maybe Godzilla
because Godzilla physically hurts you
Godzilla
[Music]
Caleb because he's the strongest
no I think that there's it's a lot
slower paced on movies and it's a lot
quicker paced on TV shows but on movies
you get to perfect what you made a
mistake on which I like about so I like
them equally the same not in the near
future but in the future R&B blues Amy
Winehouse because she was really good at
singing R&B blues okay guys I need to
tell them what my favorite song is
enough
Oh favorite song I don't even know maybe
suddenly of John Bell eons conversations
with my wife what am i into right now
Friday Night Lights actually queer I
changed my mind
queer I oh I always have you know I saw
so for Jonathan
to stay true to who you are know out you
mouth thank you oh thank you so much a
wig a pink one that I wore when I was
like 11 Blake Lively or Linnea oh I'm
the worst of these um maybe Leonardo
DiCaprio just because I play with my
dogs
or fish I have English Mastiffs three of
them Dulli
Ronnie Reggie and then I have a cat -
Hermione oh go outside with my sister
and played badminton
[Music]
enola homes diaries or that i've never
even asked this question before because
i haven't spoken about her yet i
couldn't tell you because i haven't
developed the character just yet more to
come that youth is extremely powerful if
we use our voice and spread messages we
can actually save the world
these puppies were provided by
Vanderpump dogs if you would like to
learn more about these adorable little
things go visit the website Vanderpump's
dogs org
[Music]